Speaker 1: Hey, this is another one of the sort
of I mean, like, I would I guess I would use the
word unintended consequences, but maybe
it's predictable consequences. Doctors
who are now being presented with pregnant women
with cancer. Are increasingly skittish about
treating the women for fear that they could end up
arrested as a result of anti-abortion laws. And we
have to think this through. This is kind of like
the logic of it. And if you're interested in this,
there's a good article in Business Insider. A
pregnant cancer patients may die because doctors
fear treating them could now count as illegal
abortion experts say. So here's the gist of it.
Pregnant woman has cancer. You treat her for
cancer as a cancer doctor. It doesn't go well
and she dies. Or the stress of the treatment
and the cancer while under your care causes a
miscarriage. There are states criminalizing
miscarriage and with Roe v Wade overturned,
those laws are now active in many states. This
goes beyond just pregnant cancer patients. Any
patient coming coming into the emergency room
and pregnant doctors may be saying, oh, do I
need a lawyer here? Do I need a politician here
to figure out what if the treatment they need
could cause a miscarriage? Oh, but David, there is
exceptions to all this stuff. If you look at the
laws in most of these states, the exceptions are
potentially meaningless unless. I mean, listen,
we don't. Every state has different laws. But you
are increasingly having a situation here where
professional medical professionals who know what
the right course of treatment is based on medicine
are now being second guessed by politicians with
an agenda tied in to the criminal justice system.
And if it means jail time, if a politician gets
their way, if X, Y, or Z happens as a result,
direct or indirect of the treatment you provide
to a pregnant woman, be it cancer or any other
kind of emergent situation in an emergency room,
are doctors really going to be providing the best
care in those situations? It seems that the answer
is no. So I will link to this article. I would I
would encourage you to check it out. And you
could end up in a situation where doctors say,
I'm not comfortable administering chemo, which
you need because you're pregnant, and it could
end up with me in legal hot water. Now, I am sure
that the right would say that is not the intent
of these laws. But as we have learned many times,
the intent and the consequences are two different
things and in many cases could be completely
divorced from each other. So predictable,
horrifying. The United States of America in
some states in a post Roe v world era in 2022